okay good evening everybody and welcome
to tonight's planet committee meeting my
name is peter richards and i will be
chairing tonight's meeting um some
housekeeping first of all first of all
mobile phones if you could turn them off
preferably to silent um as long as
they're uh they're not gonna disturb the
flow of the meeting i don't mind you
using them um but uh please if you would
have them on silent at a minimum we're
not expecting a fire alarm so if one
does go off follow us we will be meeting
over in the car park next to the
windmill
and we will make sure you're all checked
off and everyone is out safely before
you make your way home
this is a meeting in public it is not a
public meeting so only those people have
registered to speak will be permitted to
do so i will call you forward at the
appropriate time you'll be invited to
sit at one of the three chairs in front
of you when you have finished um if you
wouldn't mind using the desk wipes just
to give the place a quick wipe down and
the hand sanitizer gel that'd be great
the microphones there is a button in the
center when you click that it will turn
red and you will be live so please make
sure that is red when you when you are
starting and that would be great
introductions and then in that case so
to my far right we have sophie jarrett
who is our committee services uh
representative to my immediate right we
have mason nash our solicitor and then
our planners in a particular order are
joe brook emily napier and we have
richard gardner to my immediate left who
is our planning manager richard i think
you've got a statement to make
thank you mr chairman just to clarify
that my role tonight is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
wonderful thank you very much let's get
tucked into the full meeting agenda so
first item is apologies for absence
sophie do we have an apologies thank you
chairman we have apologies from
councillors adam and fleming tonight
marvelous thank you very much members do
we have any disclosures of interest
council mills
thanks mr chairman um item four on the
agenda that's uh application two two
stroke zero zero six six six stroke
f.u.l
uh i'm known to the applicant used to
live in my award but i've come to this
meeting with open mind mr chairman
lovely thank you very much um i have
received uh an email in relation to um
to item six application 220382
ful and 2200 383 lbc
an email from the applicant i'm assuming
that went to everyone i'm seeing nod so
we'll put a blanket disclosure in for
that anyone else got any other things
they want to disclose at this point
no marvelous okay minutes of our last
meeting are we all happy with the
minutes of the 27th of april and the
11th of may a quick nod or thumbs up
would be sufficient
that looks like it's unanimous yep
perfect okay let's move to our first
item on the agenda our first application
on tonight's agenda which is application
2200 666 ful idli cut estate barnes and
italicate our presidential officer is
joe brook joe over to you
thank you chair
let me just open the presentation
the application site is located in the
open countryside approximately 0.7
kilometers
kilometers from its cut and
approximately 0.9 kilometers from white
coat
as indicated by the black doctor for you
the application site is not within any
landscape or historic designations view
of the application site are available
from the public road as well as the
public footpath which is cited circa 55
meters away to the north east
as you can see public footpath
application site
whiteboard
this application is seeking permission
for the development of two dwelling
houses and the erection of a detached
garage within the open countryside so
plan before you
apologize
public footpath runs down
there's the application site building
there and i will go into more detail
if permitted the application will allow
two dwayne houses as disguised so plot
one and two located here with the
associated cartilage
barn b before you has prior approval
already and extend permission to be
converted to a dwelling house and the
class q legislation
and barney also has extended permission
at this time
to a one house
under also class q legislation the
proposed garage will be to rear the
vermont site and access has already been
permitted
over here and it has already been
implemented
this is the application site at this
moment in time the barn is no longer in
existence as you can see by the photo
before you
this is the dwayne house to the left of
the previous principal elevation so as
you can see currently under construction
and this is the 2019 class q permission
for one dwelling house
slightly to the other side
this is the application for you
uh in summary it would permit the
coloured finish render of the white
block work large cladding kingspan
profile roofing
fenestration details
and large vertical clad into the gable
elevations if permitted
this is the pros carriage
this is opposed garage once again very
in keeping with the dwelling that's
called in rendered to the wolves
two bay garage single story
this is the barn that was previously
there which was permitted for the
conversion of the dwelling house which
is no longer in existence
in summary chair there have been two
previous conversions approved a class q
and planning permission both were
founded on the existence of a building
to convert this site
the building is now has been demolished
as there is no longer a building to
convert neither the class q approval nor
the subsequent planning permission can
be lawfully completed
consequently this application is for the
development of two new build dwellings
in the open countryside which is
contrary to policies cs15 cs16 and as10
with no material considerations to
indicate otherwise
officer recommendations therefore
refusal
if you do look at the update sheet you
will notice
the one update and that is from indicate
paris council
in support of the application
thanks jeff
joe thank you very much i was going to
draw members to the update sheet as well
and you'll note from the report
that the committee trigger has come
about as a result of parish council
support will member support the parish
council are not here tonight but the the
update sheet does summarize uh their
representations um we will therefore
call for our first speaker of the
evening who is andrew murphy and our
applicant richard truman would you like
to make your way forward gentlemen
thank you
and when you are ready and settled you
will have three minutes i'll give you a
30-second warning um mr murphy i'm
presuming you're going to do most of the
talking and mr truman is here for
questions
marvellous so whenever you're ready and
comfortable the floor is yours
thank you chairman
you will recall the committee meeting of
the 2nd of february when this planning
application was recommended for refusal
and was refused
the plans submitted with this
application are exactly the same as
those submitted before
the only difference is that the current
application is accompanied by a
comprehensive report written by the
structural engineer who monitored the
barn conversion
to recap class q prime approval to
change the use of barn c to three houses
was obtained by the farmer in
2019 and mr truman to my left bought
barncy in 2021 and got planning
permission to reduce the number of
houses from three to two to remove
concrete introduce soft landscaping and
renewable energy
his family will live in one of those two
houses
he began the conversion of vanci in
august 2021 in good faith and relying on
the farmers original 2019 structural
report
however as the conversion continued it
became apparent to mr truman's
structural engineer that the amount of
wood decay was greater than identified
by the original structural report
after the roofing sheets were removed
the structure became unstable and
dangerous
mr truman was advised by his structural
engineer to dismantle most of the timber
frame and carry out repairs at ground
level
unfortunately the barn conversion had
advanced so far that the building was no
longer capable of functioning as an
agricultural building but further
conversion was not possible due to
structural failures and health and
safety responsibilities
committee members in february were
sympathetic to the predicament faced by
mr truman
but without an up-to-date structural
report you were unwilling to grant
planning permission
the current planning application has
carried out your recommendation
the new structure report achieves the
following
it is dated 2022 and is up to date it is
written by the qualified structural
engineer who monitored the barn
conversion works in 2021
it explains the unforeseen structural
problems that only became apparent once
the conversion was underway
it recommends dismantling the timber
frame so it can be repaired
a construction methodology sets out the
strategy for repairs and reassembling
the timber frame
and finally the structural report
confirms that the reassembled timber
frame corresponds with the previously
approved plans for the barn conversion
in other words once the works are
complete you would not notice any
difference between the two sets of
approved plans 30 seconds the house will
look like a barn conversion and use the
original materials
in conclusion mr truman has responded
positively to the advice that this
committee gave to him in february
and he has provided crucial evidence
from his structural engineer to explain
why dismantling the timber frame was
necessary and unavoidable in summer 2021
therefore i i ask that you grant
planning permission so that mr truman
can complete the project he began in
august 2021
thank you mr matthew thank you very much
indeed members do we have any questions
for either mr truman or mr murphy
don't all jump at once no
in that case gentlemen thank you very
much for your time
we will move to our next speaker who is
actually cancer penniano donald who has
registered to speak but unfortunately
has fallen ill today and i have been
provided with um what she was intending
to say so i will read that out on her
behalf clearly i can't answer any
questions that you may have
so
uh counselor donald has said i am the
ward member for eddington which includes
the parish of idliquet and i support
this planning application i attended the
planning committee on the 2nd of
february to support mr truman's
application to rebuild barn c as two
dwelling houses
committee members were sympathetic to
the difficult situation faced by mr
truman when during the conversion works
he was advised by a structural engineer
to dismantle and repair the structural
frame however without a report written
by the advising structural engineer you
were unwilling to go against the
officer's recommendation to refuse
mr truman has acted upon your
recommendation in a robust and
comprehensive up-to-date structural
report accompanies the current planning
application the original 2019 structural
report concluded the bond could be
converted however the 2022 structural
report explains that it was only during
con
conversion that the extent of the wood
decay became apparent
therefore mr truman was faced with an
impossible situation partway through the
conversion and he quite properly
followed the advice of a structural
engineer to dismantle the timber frame
on many occasions his council was
granted planning permission for the
demolition of an agricultural building
and erection of an of new house given
the fallback position of class q prior
approval
in this case the applicant attempted a
genuine barn conversion but he was
thoughted by unforeseen events
furthermore the circumstances of this
case are unusual and a grant of planning
permission will not create an
undesirable precedent for the district
the proposal has the support of the
local community and the idlik parish
council sorry parish meeting
i recommend that you grant permission
and record in the minutes the meeting of
the meeting as follows with regard to
paragraph 12 of the mppf granting plan
permission conflicts with an up-to-date
development plan but material
considerations indicate that the plan
should not be followed these material
considerations are
number one compared with class q prior
approval reference 1902 614 couq
there will be no increase in the number
of houses
two the unforeseen structural decay of
barn c during its conversion
three the recommendation of a structural
engineer to dismantle and repair the
timber frame for structural and health
and safety reasons
four the construction methodology will
ensure that the reassembly of the
building using original materials is
carried out with the integrity and cur
and corresponds with approved plans for
the barn conversion twenty one zero one
four four one ful
number five their home their homes will
sustain the rural community and support
the objectives of the mppf paragraph 79
and 80. number six removal of concrete
and new landscaping will enhance the
environment the proposed development
takes place entirely on existing
concrete hard standing
457 square meters of which will be
removed and replaced with grass
fancy sits in the sorry number seven
barn c sits in the center of the group
of buildings at indica estate barns with
permission for residential development
it is important that the proposed houses
are completed otherwise the incomplete
state of vanci will be detrimental to
visual immunity
also have note of the green credentials
of the application number one reusing
and repairing existing materials and
embodied carbon
uh taken from the dismantled barn number
two renewable energy an air source heat
pump
uh number three removal of concrete new
landscaping and biodiversity enhancement
the proposed development takes place
entirely on existing concrete hard
standing 457 square meters of which will
be removed and replaced with grass
number four electric vehicle charging
points number five showing
infrastructure with the adjacent barn
conversion vehicle access water and
electricity
finally our return to the advice of this
committee gave mr truman on the second
of february that if his structural
engineer gives a full written account of
conversion problems during summer 2021
then planning permission might be
granted
that is the extent of counselor
o'donnell's representations
we will move now as i obviously can't
answer any questions we will move now to
uh points for application of our offices
members do we have any points of
clarification you'd like to us
counselor adam
joe can i see the
photo before and after again please
so on that photo the bit
that comes halfway up what's that built
out of do you know
sorry guys do you mean there
uh below that
that's concrete block work
okay thank you that was mine
okay any other questions
council dixon
thank you chairman joe um i did read
this report this afternoon um i didn't
pick up from here that this structural
report the most recent one recommended
dismantling
is it in here i just oh did i just miss
it obviously that's what we've been
hearing dismantling and then
reconstruction and it's in the principle
section a bit under so the search report
is referenced from the last committee
yeah if you go to two seconds
somewhere in classes
yeah it's the character if you go to the
page of the community
it's about if you go to page 12
because unfortunately i've just got my
report in front of me
and if you follow yourself down from we
see like
number one and if you come down to that
section
class you assume and that goes on from
what we did last committee
okay council jennings
i'm presuming that if this
new structural report had been submitted
when they originally went for class q
they would not have got it because this
building wasn't sound
that is absolutely correct yes it
wouldn't be capable of conversion as
stated by the legislation so it would
have been a refusal
anyone else have any questions let's ask
council curtis
thanks so
so just following on from that
where the
instructional report says that the
structural failure of the columns
could not
reasonably have been foreseen prior to
the commencement of development
even if it could have been foreseen what
you're saying is that it wouldn't have
been sound and couldn't have been
converted sorry
i i shouldn't put words in your mouth
clarification on that
that's fundamentally correct the class q
legislation specifically states
reasonable convert reasonable level of
conversion and also a capable
functioning dwelling house obviously
the report states it wasn't capable of
conversion and therefore it can't
convert into a dreading house it would
have been a refusal casket stage
catholics
um
could this be considered obviously
this is an application for basically a
new build in the open country side
could it be considered as limited infill
uh the honest truth is no it's in the
open countryside so limited infill is in
reference to
lsv's to be honest because it's in the
physical confines of a village you
wouldn't even really consider
exceptional certain circumstances in all
of the settlements this is two dozen
hoses in the open countryside and that's
how we have assessed this application
am i writing the thinking limited info
is specifically for green belt issues as
well it's pretty that's the the only
time really that you can have limited
info regarding sometimes on local knees
dwellings and stuff because we have
policies that reference that so as long
as it's in the physical confines and
there's an identified need on occasion
that's limited infill but once again
that would be within an order of a
settlement and there would be other
houses within that vicinity okay thank
you
any other questions before we move into
debates
no let's move into debate who would like
to kick us off
council jennings
and obviously we've got to consider this
um as a new dwelling in the open
countryside i've got a lot of sympathy
for for the owner of this um
basically it was sold at dud um
on
as the reason for asking about the
limited infill i'm obviously very
sympathetic
to his
circumstances but i'm struggling to see
a valid planning reason how i can
support this at the moment but
i'm starting off the debate
i'll wait for other people to talk
i'm going to assume that is not a
proposal at this stage it is not a
proposal of this understand
yeah thanks mr chairman yeah i'm
just looking at that i mean it is a
difficult one but um
the appleton's carried out the um
the council's recommendations and and it
needs to be
using the old
or the original materials to rebuild and
this is this is a balance isn't it here
um
and i think they've actually
responsibility in demolishing the barn
uh because they're advised to do it
i'm
yeah i'm indeed in a bit of a dilemma
here mr chairman um i'll listen to what
i think we've got to say thank you
okay thank you very much anyone else
likes to contribute at this point
council dixon
german i'm
too simple i'm very sympathetic to this
this application but again it's the
reasons um
i just wondered if we could have the
officer's comments on the final sort of
comments that the ward member was making
that you read out as to the material
reasons for why we might go against the
officer's recommendation can we have the
officer's comments in respect of those
please specifically
we can certainly ask joe you okay with
that yeah thank you if i miss something
please say by all means so oh brilliant
thank you very much
so reusing and repairing the existing
materials and embodying carbon taking
the dismantle bomb firstly it is a
benefit that they can reuse the
materials and it is if it was built and
benefit the carbon but at the minute
there is no dwelling hose air so
the development itself would actually
cause more carbon in that sense and also
the repair and the materials you would
have to weigh against the policy which
doesn't require two open doors in the
open countryside and then there's a
traffic impact development and so forth
renewable energy any air source heat
pump yes for an existing dwelling
completely agree with that this is an
existing dwelling once again it comes
back to the issues that it doesn't court
with our policy
therefore the renewable energy argument
is going to cost more energy to build it
because it's not an according to our
policy
three removal of concrete new
landscaping biodiversity enhancement
the removal of the concrete is probably
a benefit but that could be undertaken
anyway if they so wished if someone the
owner wanted to clear up the site
new landscaping
once again you can clear at the site
there's no requirement under planning
permission to not do that the question
being is whether you would think a new
two new houses in this area is a
betterment than the open nature of it
and biodiversity enhancement i will be
honest i'm not a biodiversity expert on
that i'm not too sure what is in
reference that point john's two new
dwelling hoses in the open countryside
electric vehicle charging points
certainly beneficial we put them on all
conditions the hoses now once again
there's not two hours is there the
carbon issues of rebuilding and so forth
building two new houses
and sharing infrastructure with adjacent
barn conversions
well
they they've got permission they're
going to have the infrastructure put in
anyway so
i i think that's a neutral point in my
opinion and i think i haven't missed
anything
thank you jay station
i was just thinking to as well as a
response not not to joe but uh
obviously if the conversion i had been
able to proceed there would also have
been a carbon impact i think on that
possibly more now but that's part of the
debate
um
and
it was really as to whether or not going
against policy there was sufficient
strength there in that argument
i'm
not sure yet
cancer curtis
thanks chad i mean just
picking up emphasis points on page 13
um i do not consider that any
substantive harm would arise to the
landscape
or character and distinctiveness of the
area
i consider the proposed development
complies with policies cs5 cs9 and as-10
um
i'm
i'm really
very sympathetic to
the application on this and
struggling a little bit like i think a
few of a few of the rest of us
cancer foreign thank you chair um i'm
also sympathetic i think it's a very
difficult situation for the applicant
um
and the way i what i'm thinking is the
barn can't be rebuilt anyway
we can't go back to putting the barn
back if we don't give the permission
there are other prop other barns on the
site that are being converted
so i'm also along the same lines as
councillor curtis and councillor mills
that i think it's a very difficult one
but i'm not sure which way to go on this
okay we're gonna have to start moving
towards a proposal in a second but can't
say hence your seraphim first thank you
chair
um
i've come across lots of these in the
past in my working life and
once you start on something you will
always find something
that is more rotten than
what you thought
and
very sympathetic
with the people
that they're not going to
enlarge the footprint are they of the
building
and you probably end up actually with a
better building
from you
it's not taking up any more of the
footprint
you try and
work things in of a barn like that which
is very ugly barn
so
i'm very sympathetic towards this
application
thank you
thank you i'm i'm going to chuck in now
um because we've heard from most people
and we haven't really progressed
anywhere yet um i'm going to try and
surmise
the process that i'm going down in order
to come to the conclusion i am and
hopefully that will help you all clearly
we've heard and we've read in our
reports class q requires a building to
be convertible it needs to be of
sufficient structural quality in order
to be able to convert it to be converted
if it's not it doesn't get converted
we had a structural report that said it
was okay to be converted and therefore
class q was granted subsequently we had
another application that came in again
with a structural report saying
everything would be okay and that again
was granted
we're now in a position where that
building is no longer in existence
through
faults not uh
of the making of the uh the applicant i
i have no doubt but the reality is it's
not there anymore and it wasn't
structurally sound which is why it's not
there so the class q and the previous
plan permission that was granted were
not able to be
built out they couldn't have been
completed and therefore as a fallback
position they don't in my mind exist
so we have to consider this as two
dwellings in the open countryside
our policies are quite clear um and they
have been brought out in our report uh
courtesy of joe um that shows that uh
dwellings in the countryside of
countryside are not permissive um
and on that basis and that basis alone i
will be proposing that we do refuse in
line with the officer's recommendation
that's not to get away from the fact
that i have great sympathy for the
applicant but these are our policies and
they are
quasi we are a quasi-judicial group and
we have to make decisions based on
evidence and based on the policies that
we have um and and that is the situation
we find ourselves in so
that proposal made i would look for a
second debt or a counter proposal if
someone wants to make it
council jennings
and you have to give a valid pl planning
reason to go against officer
recommendations
um
i very reluctantly will second your
motion
thank you very much council dixon do you
want to speak
yes chairman um
i would actually like to put the
contract
reasons all i can come up with these
exceptional circumstances that the
applicant found themselves in of no
fault of their own and the structural
survey indicated that the
[Music]
structural elements should be dismantled
um very very regrettable but i'm just
thinking that
exceptional circumstances in this
situation we should perhaps override our
own policy now whether that will be
strong enough and fight enough i do not
know but i would like to think it could
be um obviously it's a situation whereby
um if it was granted there is no
there are no appeals but the
circumstances here i don't think could
be easily replicated elsewhere therefore
it should not be setting a precedent
understood um
we may have to revisit that in a bit um
but let's see how it pans out first
obviously we've had a proposal that's
been seconded that has to be taken first
um we've had a counter proposal would
anyone like to second that council
proposal counselor curtis do you want to
speak to it
yes i would like to second that proposal
on on the same grounds that council
dixon's outlined i think this
these are very very unusual
circumstances and i can't
see that this should in any way set a
precedent and we are always reminded
when we are looking at applications that
we don't take notice of precedent yeah
and indeed all applications consider on
individual merits
understood um okay so that has proposed
would be made in a second did we we may
have to revisit that in a minute but
we'll we'll take the first pros as well
as it is would anyone else like say
anything in the debate before we move to
the vote
no okay in that case the proposal is to
refuse in line with the officer's
recommendation could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
refusing
four and those against
six
so therefore that proposal fails so we
will fall back to our
second proposal which is to grant now i
do want you to please expand on your
reasons for going against our officer's
recommendation and indeed the policies
within our core strategy please
the only expansion i can give is the
situation whereby an exceptional
circumstances i think this committee
ought to have the opportunity to
override policy
and in this instance
it's not not granting class q
but it is granting permission from two
new builds in the open countryside given
the very unusual circumstances that the
applicant the development has found
itself in through no fault of their own
i have something more than that okay
council case have you got anything you'd
like to add as the seconder
i think i'd like something a bit more
robust um council crump
um i just like you know i know we're
actually in the debate rather than
points of clarification but we've
already done this already we've gone
back to points to qualification i just
like some
indication of what classifies as
exceptional circumstances
i'm not quite sure whether this does
so
some clarification would would be would
be helpful i'm sorry for putting the
officers
in a position but not at all it's vital
to ask and i think i'm in agreement with
you my understanding is exceptional
circumstances typically are reserved for
greenbelt but perhaps either richard or
joe could give us some uh help
um
yeah there is the possibility for
members to outweigh the development plan
with material considerations
um and there's various things as you
know that can be material considerations
um and the thing that you've raised so
far is exceptional circumstances around
the circumstances that led to the
demolition of the building
um
to my mind that's not a material
consideration it's certainly not one
that would outweigh the development plan
the reason i say that is it's important
members consider what's in front of them
what's in front of them is the
construction of two new dwellings
if there were a fallback for that then
that could be a material consideration
to outweigh it but there's no fallback
so all you're looking at there really is
something that happened in the past and
the reasons for it which
i think
as officers we acknowledge that's
unfortunate
um but it's not something that outweighs
the primacy of the development plan and
those important policies that restrict
new build development so my likid look
up
hopefully that helps you members would
anyone like to give us some further
clarification on reasons for granting if
indeed that is the direction we are
going in
no um
i'm gonna have to try and summarize
something for you um
along the lines of committee members
have given considerations to the
circumstances surrounding this uh
development proposal
um and in their considerations uh or in
in that deliberation have considered
that reuse of
the materials of the original building
where possible
uh in line with the structural report
that the building will be built out in
accordance with the original plans as it
would have been built had the original
been
still standing essentially
um and as a result uh there would be no
change to
or increase in in either floor area
dwellings all that sort of stuff uh on
the site um which would
not cause any further harm
than would have been had it been built
out in accordance with the class q and
if you are
that is the best i can do i'm afraid
i still won't be voting for that but
that is the best i can do
um
does anyone want to add anything to it
no
chairman the only thing i would say is
that the structural survey recommended
dismantling it was demolished but
i would draw a distinction between
dismantling and demolish demolition
yeah i'm not sure we're using the word
dismantled demolition in what i've just
said there and that was very deliberate
um we don't know that it's been
demolished it may well have been
dismantled and all the parts are still
available and that is our understanding
from the report and the information
that's been provided to us which is why
i'm saying the reuse of the materials
where they're structurally sound
richard and joe
how do you feel about what
to justify this development
um
i'm not still comfortable they are
better than what i've heard before the
reason so i'm not comfortable because
the issue of precedent we get a lot of
class queues in this district we have a
lot of conversions
um and it's important that when they
take place that they are followed and
they remain within that envelope for
whatever reason
there are obviously unfortunate
circumstances and they may happen on
other sites
so precedent concerns me
however
the chairman has summarized their
three reasons which
although weak are still reasons the
reuse of the materials
that is
i would say almost neutral
it's better that they can reuse
materials rather than being new builds
so it's an improvement on that but again
there's no
fallback there
um mimicking the original plans again
similar to the materials
it's it's verging on being neutral
it's the least we'd expect on something
that's supposed to be
um following the class q before it
um and the same with no further visual
harm so that there is the the sort of
um the embryo
of a an argument there but it's a weak
one
thanks richard i thought i did rather
well there
um now i saw some hands go up over here
i think cancer crump did you have
something to say
yeah it was just like yeah i think
richard took side about the president um
i do have immense sympathy for the
applicant and to discover that
but you know just be acting
dispassionately
i think is very weak you know it was a
good effort like mr chairman uh i
couldn't have done any better so i'll
i'll give you some phrase for that um
but i'll certainly
um and if another application came
forward you're similar we are you know
we're on dangerous ground in my opinion
and i think
you know i won't be supporting it i'm
afraid
okay thank you council curtis did i see
your hand go up
no councillor mills
yeah thanks richard i mean can we um
in our deliberations
the council asked for a um
full written report from from the
structural engineer
they gave it to us and gave him the
reasons why are we not are we accepting
that or not
we've accepted the report it performs
part of the
consideration or
we accepted it
well i mean it's a structural report
that forms part of our evidence it has
been reviewed within the context of the
report and clearly has um i mean joe has
set out exactly his position on that
um
but the alliance did did what it was
asked of him yeah okay i
yeah i i'm gonna
putting aside what's been said in terms
of the reasons and all that sort of
stuff and the proposal that's been put
in front of us we will have to take that
proposal in a second i will just
reiterate the point that um with class q
it's very different from your standards
sort of properties um there are very
strict guidelines and that as i said
earlier um those those properties have
to be convertible they have to be
structurally sound to be converters if
they're not they don't get their
permission um if we
now
and we would be setting the precedent by
saying well this had a class queue but
it wasn't quite structurally sound so
we'll let it get taken down and then
we'll have it rebuilt on the basis that
it you know it wasn't wasn't ideal and
it was circumstances out of one's
control
everyone that has a barn would come back
and do exactly the same thing it wasn't
structurally sound we're taking it down
we need to have evidence and we didn't
have that at the time we clearly we have
that evidence but evidence shows that
the bond couldn't be converted
so therefore it wouldn't have been
granted the class q permission and
therefore wouldn't be granted it's
planning permission
that's where we're at
now i understand and completely
sympathize that we members would want to
grant this but we have to have sound
policy reasons for granting two
properties in the open countryside at
the moment it seems that
one person that has proposed that we
don't grant this has come up with the
only reasons to go in favor of it i need
a lot more help from you
either that or we're going to have to
revisit another proposal
so unless anyone else has got anything
they want to say at this point
we will have to take the proposal to
grant for the reasons that i set out
no one else got anything to say in that
case we're going to move to that
proposal then so the proposal is to
grant for the reasons that i set out
previously could those in favor of
granting plane
okay
ah trying to be expedient as possible we
do need to have conditions if we're
going to grant
um so we'll go through those now joe if
we're if we're minded to grant could you
please list the conditions that would be
attached to this proposal
the standard time limit
corners for the approved plans
uh material scheduled to be submitted
and approved by the council
prior to recursion the development a
landscaping scheme
uh obstacle glaze into bedrooms two and
three ensuite the mechanical drive barn
a to be removed as indicated on plans
pd rights and the part one class a b c d
e g h and part two class a and c
and
last bits
uh climate change checklist evc charging
points um
refuse bins
down pipes so water capacity minimum the
capacity water and broadband
connectivity given the open countryside
location
cancer care is signal first
would we also include a can were we
minded to grant would we also include a
condition
something along the lines of the reuse
of as much as possible of the existing
material is that
i i think the answer is going to be yes
but we just get the the wording given
that our reason
or the reason that has been put forward
is to include all and reuse as much as
possible
bear with
if you're looking to reuse the materials
in the barn that's been demolished
it would be very hard to enforce that
because we couldn't prove that they were
the same materials or where they've been
for the last
eight months
which sadly does make our position a
slightly weaker um counselor
am i
misunderstood and misheard
was the mention of heat source pumps
especially application so that was part
of the the green issues green
credentials
uh for if you're minded to to grant this
i would ask that
a heat source heat
yeah or whatever it's called ground
source heat pump yeah wild and lazarus
is conditioned because that was one of
the swaying factors in people's uh
well i believe it was one of the swaying
factors and people's
decision
point noted can we or can we condition
that there is that i think it's in
accordance with plans and it does have
one on the plans
so it's already encompassed in that so
we've got that covered through the in
line with plants cancer kendall just to
ask if we could uh
add a note
for them for the materials to be reused
i know it's very enforceable but it's a
note it's in line with what we've been
saying i think that's a good idea
yeah
okay we're happy we've got all our
conditions through
are you
a little happier about our reasoning
you're satisfied but we can go to a vote
i'm satisfied you can go to a vote my
view on your reasons remains the same
understood okay in that case we will now
move to a vote the proposal made by
council dixon is to grant application
2205 8f
um could i have a show of
sorry no that's not that's the next one
i do apologize
oh this is stressful right now
uh application reference 2200 666 ful
estate barnes um could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor of
granting for the reasons given
six
and those against
three
four those abstaining
none therefore committee resolves to
grant application 2200 666 fuel estate
plans for the reasons given
marvelous
okay
let's move on to our next application
hopefully
this will be a little more
straightforward
um okay so the upcoming application
reference is uh 2200 528 ful uh lower
braille's lodge in lower brailles our
presenting officer is emily napier emily
as soon as you're comfortable and ready
to go the floor is yours
thank you chair
the application before you relates to
the replacement of an existing barn with
new garage and tractor store the
application submitted is retrospective
and the principle of the replacement of
the barn was already established under
an application
1901163 ful which was granted on the
18th of september 2019.
the application site is located in
lowbrails and is located within the
conservation area and area of
outstanding natural beauty
the property is located within the
curtidage of the listed building lower
brailles lodge and sits the north east
of the adjoining sadler's patch
which is also a listed building
the building is located to the north of
high street
and sits to the rear of properties which
front onto the high street these being
sadler's thatch
wayside cottage and kits cottage
the property's rear outlet are directed
towards the application site
and currently bounded by a brick wall at
the end of their gardens which are
approximately between seven to seven
point five meters in length which you
can just see here
the garage
the building proposed to replace the
existing is in this location here on
this map
to the north of the site there's also a
public right of way
screened by
substantial vegetation on the rear
boundary
to the east directly adjoining the
building sits forward cottage
the retrospective application proposes
the following amendment to the already
approved development
the height will be increased by 1.1
metres the structure has been
constructed 0.5 meters lower than as
previously approved so the visual height
increase would appear more like 0.6
meters
the there is also an increase in width
of approximately 0.65 meters and depth
by approximately 0.2 meters which you
can see
there is a general outline of the
previously granted scheme in green here
to give you an indication of the change
in scale
further amendments to the detailed uh
finish and design have been submitted
following comments from the conservation
team including changes to rain water
guttering and oak lintels over existing
doors and windows
here you can just see this is the uh
the building as currently constructed
and as noted there will be some
as part of the recommendation for
officers some changes to to the details
this just shows you the relationship
between the properties fronting high
street
and the the building as constructed
and this just shows you the relationship
with the adjoining property forge
cottage
officers are satisfied that the modest
changes to the scale and design of the
property are acceptable in regards to
the setting of the adjacent listed
buildings amenities of adjoining
occupiers and wider designations
officer's recommendation is to grant
permission for the development subject
to the conditions set out within the
report thank you chair
emily thank you very much indeed
okay our first speaker on this item is
aims vivian ellis
miss ellis make your way forward please
wherever you're comfortable
okay when you're settled and comfortable
if you want to press the button in the
middle of your microphone it'll turn red
and as soon as you're ready you'll have
three minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up otherwise
it's over to you
committee it's an outrage that someone
so well versed in planning procedures
should attempt to manipulate the
regulations and take a calculated gamble
that they will be granted permission
retrospectively this totally
unauthorized backyard development bears
no resemblance to the approved plans the
only intact item from the original is
one barn door to the front elevation
every other detail has been altered at
least 12 planning breaches have been
identified demolition of the historic
barn was supported on the basis that the
replacement would be similar in
character of modest scale retain the
appearance of an outbuilding and be
subservient to the main dwelling it
fulfills none of these criteria
all character features such as lintels
and single wooden windows have been
replaced with white domestic
upvc why because i believe its intended
purpose is a dwelling
yeah this application would not have
been approved as demonstrated by the
amendments to the original plans before
permission was granted these include a
reduction in height to 4.4 meters
reduction in footprint and removal of
the gable m window why then is the
increased height of 5.2 meters now
acceptable the building dominates the
three properties behind and spans the
full width of kit scouting wayside
cottages resulting in increased use of
artificial light in winter without
greenery they are overwhelmed with the
wall of grey slate the original barn was
completely unobtrusive
the elements deemed important to the
original application i.e design
character materials and setting now seem
to have little red relevance according
to the impact and design statements in
the committee report
this building is cited nine meters from
the nearest dwelling not 12 meters as
stated and the overshadowing impact is
substantial it is around 20 taller than
approved which is not insignificant it
does not comply with policy se2 of the
ndp the build is out of context the
materials in design are inappropriate
for an outbuilding within the curtilage
of a listed building painting the upvc
windows brown will not mitigate the harm
done to the historic setting and the
neighbours
that is like putting a wet paper towel
on a gaping wound there are many
compelling reasons for a refusal not
least that to do anything else would
make a mockery of the whole planning
process
protect our conservation area and aomb
from unauthorized development
improve the lives of the occupants of
wayside cottage and kitscote by reducing
the overwhelming wall of slate which has
become their view send the clear message
that you cannot deliberately manipulate
the system on this scale
and hope to succeed on behalf of the
villagers of brails 12 of whom have
raised stronger objections and all those
people who play by the rules i would
urge you to set the right example and
refuse this application many thanks
that was just under your three minutes
well thank you very much yeah perfect um
members do we have any questions from
zelis please
nope
okay in that case thank you very much
for your time and contribution this
evening you're most welcome to make your
way back to your seat behind you
counselor hoggins can stay where she is
because she is our next speaker
um now casper do you know
go ahead while you're doing that i will
tell you uh what's going on i think you
know the drill anyway um you'll have
five minutes i'll give you a 30 second
warning before your time is up otherwise
whenever you're ready the floor is yours
um
i'm almost embarrassed to be here today
giving evidence against the approval of
this application for retrospective
planning permission
i am embarrassed because rather than
dealing with a very serious and blatant
disregard for the original plans that
were approved officers now seek to wash
their hands of this matter and are
recommending approval of this ugly
dwelling masquerading as a tractor store
the officer shared a photograph earlier
that clearly showed a staircase i'm also
embarrassed because this authority's
failure to act properly has meant that a
near octogenarian has had to come here
this evening to give evidence
i dare anyone to underestimate ms
ellis's grasp of the development of this
building and her knowledge of the
activity leading up to this committee
meeting the pictures before you clearly
show
the remnants of the historical building
this dwelling has replaced this
application for retrospective planning
permission is i believe a calculated
manipulation of the planning system to
obtain approval for a building that
would have been refused via the proper
channels indeed a subsequent application
for a height increase in dormer windows
was withdrawn because the planners
indicated that refusal was likely
the original approved plans have totally
been disregarded to achieve a two-story
edifice the applicant wanted with dormer
windows now being replaced by roof
lights
planning enforcement failed to act in
july 2021 when the building was a shell
but it was evident the height and
footprint had been vastly increased and
windows and doors reconfigured almost 12
months on we now have a recommendation
for approval of a structure which before
it was built was going to be refused
permission precisely what the applicant
perhaps set out to achieve many
residents believe that the retrospective
plans submitted show inaccuracies and
are exceptionally ambiguous with very
few measurements
some objectives feel that these could be
described as being nefarious by a
mission in fact all submitted plans have
lacked measurement detail in order to
bamboozle us further the name of the
historic property has been changed from
the old post office to lower braille's
lodge
this appears to have happened after the
applicant received detailed
pre-application advice in january 2019
referring to the old post office
he states the conservation officer
states the single story outbuilding
appears to be victorian and is covered
by the listing to main historic
continuity and the site's historic
contribution to the conservation area it
is desirable to maintain the building
and convert it for storage or a garage a
modest extension of a sympathetic rural
design may be acceptable i put it to you
committee that has clearly shown from
the photographs in front of you the
building is anything but a sympathetic
rural design and cannot be described as
a modest extension to the original
footprint by any stretch of the
imagination the same conservation
officer objected to plans submitted in
november 2020 he states by virtue of the
proposed style scale and character it is
considered that the proposal will
compete with and detract from the
character of the listed building in
historic development as such the setting
will not be preserved unless and
substantial harm will be caused the new
proposal lacks the traditional form and
interest it would appear more as a
standard dwelling type this would insert
a competing element within the setting
of the listed buildings including subtle
as that erode the character of the site
and diminish the character of the
conservation area neither would be
preserved
ladies and gentlemen of this committee
this is precisely what has been built in
disregard of any advice recommendations
or previous objections he has built a
modern unsympathetic building with no
regard for its position in the
conservation area it will be a travesty
if consent is given for this obvious
dwelling rather than tractor store and
will be a very poor reflection on sdc
facts speak for themselves but the
camera never lies these pictures show a
dwelling that bears no resemblance to
the original approved plans
or by the conservation officer's advice
by approving this retrospectively you'll
be indicating to others that it is
acceptable to ignore conservation
officers and pre-application in advice
in fact it will tell future applicants
not to worry about approved plans just
build whatever you want because you will
get permission to build it
retrospectively
let's show developers large and small
that we s at sdc mean business and that
our word and insight matter and that we
will not tolerate such blatant disregard
for our authority on planning and that
we treasure our conservation or areas
and the fact that our villages are
within the conservation area thank you
that's what huggins thank you very much
members do we have any questions for our
ward member please
um i will ask them could you bring can
we go back a couple of photos
please
i just want to be clear
one more
another one
is that the that's what's been built is
that what is what has been built yes
okay that's helpful
thank you council jennings
there's only any photos anywhere of the
of the original
there is there is if that's that's the
original there yeah
is it possible to zoom in on that
and you can clearly see
on that picture
can you not that that it wasn't
agricultural building because the top
window the top opening there was never a
window that was a place where the
smaller bales of hay and straw as they
used to be made would have been would
have been positioned up there i'm a bit
of a barn expert really from the
yorkshire dales thank you
any other questions for our ward member
please
no
in that case council hogan thanks very
much for your time contribution this
evening thank you ladies and gentlemen
let's move into uh points gratification
for officers anyone cancer mills first
of all thanks mr chairman um
can we
can we go back on a couple of
photographs not
oh i'm interested in that one but then
it showed
not that one
keep going
it was one
uh very close up that was
bolted onto the house
no
sorry
yeah
no
there was a
uh it i mean it clearly showed that
this as the um
alice pointed out this upvc on there and
it
on the that's it that's it
yeah i mean it doesn't look much like a
tractor store does it but uh
yeah okay thank you thank you okay
council jennings
thank you um
was upvc windows originally
granted in the previous sorry in the
previous application
there's one question i have another to
follow that up
we will ask the officers but thank you
i don't have that information available
but i can get that out for you quickly
just to see previous plans do you want
to fire off your second question okay um
and we'll see if we can answer that as
well and the percentage
obviously from what was granted and
what's been built there the percentage
of
um volume increase roughly very roughly
so in order to answer those we just
think we're going to take a two minute
german just so the original plans and
permissions to be brought up so great
we're going to take two minutes
okay sorry for that brief interlude i
think we have uh an answer to the
question now so how many of you if
you're right to answer that question
from cancer jennings
yes thank you chair um in terms of the
windows we um
the materials weren't indicated on the
approved plans and there wasn't a
condition requiring the use of timber
windows so it wouldn't have been
enforceable um in in that regard thank
you and then in terms of the size
um it's difficult for us at this stage
to to calculate the overall volume um
but i would expect in terms of the
square meter ridge
and so that would be from the additional
width and the additional depth it would
be approximately
1.443 1.5 square meters larger
okay um
we saw some photos earlier on i think
were uh either submitted by our objector
or by our world member um they were
quite small for my benefit would you
mind bring them up one by one and just
zoom in so we can have a better look at
them please
i'm okay with that one
okay i'm happy with that one thank you
okay thank you
i'm we're just going through this first
of all
calm down
oh wait this is a view from the neighbor
property i presume
yeah thank you okay next one
i think we need to get you a new laptop
thank you
bear with which let's just go through
these and then we can come back and
revisit one you might want to see i'm
assuming you want to see the last one
because of the red dots i thought you
might
we'll go back to that in a sec
okay thank you
okay thank you
similar to that one previously but
without the it looks like it's before
conversion okay thank you very much um
if we could go back to the one
oh
we've got another one forgive me
the building question is the one on the
right i'm assuming
marvelous
okay thank you if we could go back to um
i think it was number six it was listed
as
uh so browse lug uh browse lodge
building structure that one out please
and there were some red dots on there
i'm assuming the red dots along that
roof line indicate uh either a previous
roof line or a granted permission refund
but if you clarify for me that would be
great
these were the photos provided by the
public speakers so i can't confirm that
i'm afraid
understood thank you
um council curtis uh
well obviously you've seen that
that's exactly my question okay
okay
i have two other speakers two other
people indicating they want to ask
questions so i'll go to them first then
we'll come back to that council jennings
three i'm presuming
that's the large slate roof
that is where the solar panels are going
on
are they windows or
so
i'm guessing this by the solar panels
being on the
on the house on that side of the house
a bit further up the road or
the part of the house that the solar
panels will also be going on this side
yeah they are they are on the
adjacent property
so they're facing sounds
is the roof right
on the other side
that's great
i'm not sure where a few seem just for
me to double check the solar panels well
in the previous application which was uh
approved there was the
um
construction of new raised roof with
solar panels
that previous approval related to um
more than the the application before you
so another part of the site as well so
we're just considering what's in front
of us
thank you very much okay
so no solar panels can you turn your
microphone off please cancel jenny
cancer mills you had a question um
actually one of the photos i wanted to
see i i saw it thank you
okay um as a point of clarification can
i ask ms ellis to come back forward to
one of the chairs for me
um i believe this the photo that we were
discussing earlier on the photo number
six with the red dots is one that you've
provided could you explain to us what
the red dots are please
if you wouldn't mind putting your
microphone on as well sorry i should
have said
thanks
i uh
measured what um a meter was in terms of
bricks which was
eight bricks high
based on my own property
and drew a line on the roof where the
approved application
i believe that's the roof line of the
approved application so in in summary
it's your assessment of where the roof
line would have been yes in what's been
up before before i demonstrate that
before it was increased lovely that's
great thank you very much if you
wouldn't mind if you could turn your
microphone off again and then if you'd
make your way back that'd be great thank
you very much
council coast i think that answers your
question
listen i have a lot of you may want to
could we see the original plans as well
please and so alongside if possible
this is the previously approved scheme
okay while you're looking at that does
anyone else have any questions or points
of clarification they may wish to make
at this point uh council dixon please
can we confirm that we have heard words
about the the vast slate roof with slate
uh condition or part of the plans the
previous plans for that roof
we are considering what's in front of us
now so um i i mean i'm just wondering if
it would have been if if it's if it's if
it's being built incorrectly with the
slate or if the slate was indeed
appropriate
thank you chet um
it's worth noting that the conservation
officer was consulted on this um and
they considered that the materials that
have been proposed as part of this
application were acceptable um i also
alluded in my presentation to just some
minor details to be changed to to
slightly bring it back to the previous
character that was approved and that's
oakland tools over the doors and windows
as you can see
in those plans before you
i appreciate we're all very keen tonight
um please wait until i call you in to
speak you just put your hand up i will
see you i will nod and i will write you
down and you'll be called in order
cancel mills first please thank you um
are they windows or our solar panels i'm
looking at the
windows their window that's all i need
thank you cancer curtis please
you put a hand up a second ago
just as i said put your hand up you went
are you trying to cause me trouble
tonight everyone
okay have we got any more points
clarification can we move to the debate
yes who would like to start us in the
debates
anyone i'm going to start picking up
people counselor curtis okay
looking at the original proposal
it was part demolition of the existing
barn reconstruct to form
new machinery store
we seem to have gone way way beyond that
and i think it's
i find it very interesting that
you know the the next application to
lower the barn to construct the small
door boiler that was withdrawn the
replacement
to me this seems
i'm very sympathetic to the
cognitive award member
that this seems to me to be
really
taking the nick
okay um
i was just i'll just remind you that
taking the mick isn't a planning reason
um for a start uh we have to consider
what's put in front of us we're not here
to consider previous applications uh
whilst they're helpful and
from from an information perspective we
have to consider what's put in front of
us so it's whether you think what is in
front of you now is acceptable in
planning terms if you don't believe it
to be please give me planning reasons
why you would want to go against the
officer's recommendation counselor
kendall did her hand up first
thank you but before i go to debate
let's have one quick question of
clarification really quickly is the
building that's there that we're looking
for to approve or not approve tonight is
that habitable as
a house or is it a garage as a store
what is it
the floor plans um of the submitted
indicate that it will be used as garage
and store
we have included as part of the
recommendation within the report um a
condition to state that it would be
ancillary
um to the main dwelling which mean it
wouldn't be able to be used for um
anything independent of the main
dwelling house
thank you that's what i wanted to
clarify um
yeah it's big and i i get that and it's
bigger than it should have been
however a lot of the comments about this
are
i think related to the size
but also they're related to the fact
this is a retrospective application
and i think a lot of the concern coming
from objectives and i can completely
understand your concern and how
aggrieved you feel
but it feels like a lot of that agree
the feeling is because of the way this
has happened
and the fact that it's a retrospective
application there's a parish council as
well i completely understand that they
sympathize with it however i'm not
seeing strong enough grounds
to go against the officer's
recommendation here and i'm also minded
that if we were to go against the
application i i put myself in the in the
in the in the shoes of a potential um
planning inspector come to look at this
to go to appeal
what would the planning inspector think
well i think the planning inspector
would would look back at what the uh
officer's recommendation was and that
inspector may very well
overturn what we said
leaving us with costs etc etc all the
things that go with that so i'm trying
to work out
i can't see the planning grounds to go
against this so with that in mind
although i've said it very badly i'm
happy to propose that we grant your
recommendation
thank you councillor kendall i'm going
to second that um and in
the very same tone it infuriates me that
we have retrospective planning
applications it really does we have we
have a planning framework for a reason
um and we should stick to that and hear
to it however within that planning
framework there is an allowance for
applications to be retrospective and
again we have to work within that
framework
it is frustrating i completely
understand that
but i can see no sound planning reasons
to go against the officer's
recommendation what i would ask as a
proposer cancer kendall we have and
condition for outbuilding shall remain
ancillary to the main dwelling i would
like to change that to outbuilding shall
remain ancillary to the main dwelling as
a garage or tractor store 100
fantastic perfect um council jennings i
think you indicated next
i was going to say a lot a lot of what
you actually just said i i appreciate
there's a lot of feeling that people
don't like like it but i think that's
more aimed towards the previous
application which was granted um they
are allowed to put
upvc windows in there they are allowed
to
gray slate it's 1.4 square meters larger
the height has gone up but it's only
gone up by half by 0.6 because they've
lowered the house they've lost it then
lowered this building by half a meter so
those red dotted lines aren't actually
correct it's only gone up by half a
meter
um don't like it
but i say they have to give very good
valid planning reasons
normally um to go against officers
recommendations so
i'll be going uh with grant on this one
thank you very much i'm just going to
say that those red line dotted lines may
well be correct but we haven't measured
them so i wouldn't declare that
absolutely not they may well be but your
points otherwise are valid counselor
mills yeah thanks mr chairman yeah
the whole thing is bigger
the windows at the top it doesn't like
doesn't look like a tractor stores at
all but um
but the conditions are that this is what
it's going to be used for so even the
top area can't be used for accommodation
so based on the
[Music]
the um additional
um
amendments to the condition to to
include
um that it it must be retained as
storage and garage purposes that would
that would be something that we would be
all of it okay thanks
okay before we move to a vote anymore
for any more
no last chance okay let's move to a vote
then so proposal is to grant application
twenty two zero zero five two eight full
in line with the officer's
recommendation but with the addition of
the words as garage or tractor store and
uh condition four could i please have a
show of hands for those in favor
one two
five four five and those against
for five
wonderful so that leaves it to
chairman's decision i'm going to
maintain the decision i took initially
and therefore committee resolves to
grant application 2200 528 ful lower
braille's lodge in lower brailles
okay
let's move to our final application of
the evening um now we have two in one we
will hear them both together but we will
have to vote on them independently
application reference are two two zero
zero three eight two ful and two two
zero zero three eight three l b c that
is seventy wood barrington in ulster um
our potential officers once again emily
napier emily over to you
thank you chair
the application proposes the erection of
first floor and ground floor extensions
to the existing listed building
the existing building is a grade two
listed property and lies within wood
bavington a modest hamlet within the
parish of soul surprise
a public right of way runs adjacent to
the east of the application site which
you can see here bounded in red
the building's character
uh comes from its small-scale simple
form typical to that of a rural workers
dwelling
you can see here in the um
the block plan the the location of the
proposed extensions and the photographs
i will take you through shortly
are aimed towards the the elements where
the extensions are going to be the most
visible
you can see here this is the east
elevation and this would largely be
retained you can see there is a an
existing um lean-to pvc extension which
we'll see in more detail shortly
this is the uh
site
sorry
this is a view from the north um towards
the north elevation of the the property
where there are um first floor
extensions including a dormer and cat
slide roof proposed
and this is a view towards the south and
west elevations
you can see here an existing pvc lean 2
extension
this has
previously been
granted for the replacement
of the of the extension with a more
synthetic timber um addition largely
of a similar footprint to to this
uh you can see from the photographs that
there are two principal elements
distinguishable on the property
um with the original being this timber
framed
element and then a later 19th century
victorian edition which you can see here
there are also some more modest later
editions um
the proposed extensions will be
constructed from a mixture of materials
including steel with aluminium framed
glazing metal fascias render and tiles
to match existing
and this photograph just shows you the
existing outbuilding which also forms
part of the curtain of the list building
and it's proposed as part of the
extensions
that there will be a link between the
two
this photograph just shows you the site
from the public right-of-way you can see
here this is the east elevation with the
south elevation where there is proposed
to be first floor extension just here
this
is a view of the south elevation you can
see the different elements proposed as
part of the application
first floor here and then the aluminium
framed glazed link extension and the
rendered flat roof extension
again here we can just see this from the
view
from the the west you can see the the
ground floor extension projects forward
beyond that existing uh principal
elevation of the existing and original
cottage where this was that chimney that
was visible
from one of the earlier photographs
as demonstrated by previous decisions
which are referred to in the officers
report officers do not object the
principle of a sympathetic setting
sympathetically scaled and designed
extension to the property however in
this instance the proposed extensions by
reason of their unacceptable scale
design and sighting would visually
compete and overwhelm the original
cottage which is of modest proportions
and this would significantly erode its
historic character
the proposals fail to preserve the
significance of the listed building
causing less than substantial harm which
is not outweighed by public benefits
officers therefore recommend refusal for
the reasons set out in pages 34 and 35
of the agenda thank you chair emily
thank you very much indeed let's move to
our first speaker on this item who is
councillor kim james of salford prize
parish council good evening mr james
castle james i should say
i think you're pretty well versed in
what's going on now um and previously
experienced probably also so you'll have
three minutes i presume it'll just be
you speaking yes um
okay so you'll have three minutes i'll
do this second one for the end otherwise
the time is yours when you're ready
thank you chairman chairman members the
parish council considered this planning
application in great detail and in
accordance with our salford southern
neighborhood development plan and the
salvador's parish design statement the
council concluded based on the policies
of the neighborhood development plan
that the proposed alterations will
improve and meet the requirements of
modern day family living
and by doing so preserve and enhance the
longevity of this listed building
which was an
original farm labourers cottage that was
in very poor state of repair the parish
council consider the extension design
shows simplicity and subservience to the
the main dwelling
preserves and enhances the character and
appearance whilst maintaining a local
distinctive appearance that contributes
to the historic and cultural built
heritage of wood bevington
the parish council consider the scale of
the proposed extension alterations
are modest the cat slide extension is
small in scale the glass link is
insignificant and there is no
substantial harm to the character of the
hamlet or to the wider landscape area
there would be no impact on neighbouring
properties by allowing this development
in our opinion this is a sustainable
development that will will preserve and
enhance this dwelling for future
generations
if prophecies like this are to survive
they must be sustainable for 21st
century living whilst retaining the
historic past
we must ask ourselves do we want to
protect properties such as this and and
for them to surprise survives i and if
the answer is yes we must be flexible
and accommodating in our decisions thank
you chairman
thank you council james well within your
time members do we have any questions we
would like to ask parish council
no councilman else
thanks mr hi hi kim um
i probably could answer the
um
so but is this in the conservation area
no it's not it's in the arden special
landscape
that's thank you very much
okay if there are no other questions
which they don't appear to be thank you
very much your time contribution
okay we will move to our next speaker
who is mr andrew mann our agent for the
applicant or application
okay mr man i'm assuming you will be
doing all the speaking um you will have
three minutes i'll give you 30 second
warning i believe we've got your slides
up on screen is it just the one
marvelous so whenever you're ready the
floor is yours
thank you good evening members of the
planning committee my name is andrew
mann of ajm associates i became involved
in this project following the previous
application in 2020 which had already
seen considerable dialogue between the
applicant and the
conservation officer the applicant being
we're back on okay i think we're back on
again
forgive me mr man uh if you'd like to
start from the beginning uh i will
rested the clock and
it's over to you
thank you yeah my name is andrew manner
become involved in the project following
the previous application in 2020 which
had seen considerable dialogue between
the applicant mr barstow and the
conservation officer the current design
addresses the conservation officer's
various concerns and suggestions in a
positive and sensitive way given the
resultant reduction in scale of the
proposals
the limited expansion of the building
does not threaten to harm its special
character a view clearly echoed by the
parish council and neighbours notably
historic england chose not to object
despite being consulted
my focus this evening however is on the
conservation officer's latest
consultation response and the planning
officer's report both of which failed to
mention the extensive dialogue and the
design iterations following the initial
pre-application discussions
i have asked the case officer to address
this and to clarify several confusing
and misleading statements in their
report
the proposal comprises three main
elements the modification sorry number
one the modification of the existing
north extension to form a cat slide roof
over the new staircase please note this
is not an extension
the conservation officer confirms this
potentially acceptable
two the small first floor side extension
to the existing south facing gable
um without raising its ridge level which
is to remain lower than the main ridge
uh the slide actually illustrates the
existing as opposed to the to the new
uh and you can see little change
obviously on that elevation the gable
face is set back substantially from the
side of the cottage thus maintaining the
dominance of the original element
no objection is raised to this in the
conservation officer's response however
the case officer report raises objection
although its explanation is
contradictory alleging that the
proposals introduce an additional gable
and stating that this would disrupt the
rhythm and simplicity of the elevation
and visually compete with the
elevation's existing character this is
incorrect as a comparison of the
existing and proposed south and west
elevations clearly confirmed
item three a ground floor extension
connect connecting the outbuilding to
the house
the upvc conservatory already has
approval for a timber and glass
replacement so the new glass link to the
south provides similar transparency
allowing the retained victorian
structure to be visible from outside and
within but the case officer's report
cast out on this treatment despite
raising no objection to the similar
glass link on the north elevation 30
seconds
locating a kitchen as proposed allows a
str allows all the structural walls of
the existing house to remain
in summary
the additional floor area is minimal
no part of the extension project
projects beyond the sides of the
original cottage
finally the local community will benefit
from these proposals in social
environmental and economic terms and
will help to slow the decline in
availability of rural family sized homes
thank you for listening
thank you very much remember do you have
any questions for mr mann
councillor crumb
worth your while come here
um just brief question in the update
sheet um you sent an email on the 20th
of may
uh submitting amended plans
um five days before the
planning committee i just wondered
why something and bearing in mind they
do need
a while to be assessed
um
yes thank you for pointing that out um
we had been asked by the
conservation officer and the planning
officer to consider alternative
elevational treatments
um i think the reason was that they
found
um
they
i can't remember the exact reasons but
um they they seem to want us to consider
introducing
traditional timber frame
construction within the extension
we
simply provided that alternative
elevation
with a comment that um
we've produced this
um
not as a proposal
um but to illustrate the comparison
um and really just to emphasize that we
felt it was the wrong the wrong
treatment
so hence
uh it's not something that we would want
to put forward
as a firm proposal
but it was just in response to the
conservation officer's
request as
uh they've
come up with several suggestions and
ideas from the original
uh
from the original pre-app um advice
uh which we've addressed i i think we've
addressed that now um do we have any
other questions members
no
in that case both you thank you very
much your time contribution this evening
thank you right let's move two points
clarification to our offices um does
anyone have any points they would like
clarifying
speak now
no in that case oh hang on councilman
yeah um
um
oh well it says it says existing
outhouse okay now getting my mind that
is going to be joined onto that
part of the house
right
that's fine
thank you
okay any other points to be clarified
cancer adam
um by all means say no um are we able to
see the proposed ones that came in to
see the kind of direction of travel of
the heritage officer
um i'd rather talk to the ones who were
actually making a decision
anyway
thank you
okay any other points of clarification
no let's move to debate who's going to
kick us off
going to pick on someone
council dixon
i think it's only fair that i take that
an option um
i must admit
i can see the objective of making a
property more sustainable and better for
21st century living
however
i am concerned what i can look at there
is a new kitchen extension steel frame
aluminium frame glazing and render etc
render yes
obviously the only general property is
rendered um but i'm just wondering if
there's too much uh in the way of
steel aluminium and glass there so
um i can understand where council edin
might have been coming from um obviously
we don't have what's before us and what
the conservation officer would like
i think this might be a little bit too
modern for that property
um so it sounds like you're moving
towards the uh uh the
going along with the officer's
recommendation are you going to make
that as a proposal
jolly good um council candle next please
i will make it as a proposition to put
you out of your misery there i think
this is the wrong
um application really just like the
officer said i think i'm not against the
principle and as council dixon said
yes it is i think he needs something
doing to it to make to bring it up to
21st century standards this isn't it it
just doesn't work for me so i'll propose
that we refuse both of these
applications so your proposal applies to
both the full and the elderly indeed
okay marvelous cancer mills please thank
you mr jimmy i was just going to say
that i mean i don't disagree with
actually enlarging it and then making it
a a nice big house but
it's just that
metal frame uh it just doesn't fit i
know you had that horrible lean to
before but we seem to be placing one
horrible lean through with them
yeah i know beauty behold on all that
but um
i'm not agreeing with that thank you is
that a seconding or yeah i can second
that marvelous for both phil and lbc yes
mr chairman marvelous thank you very
much council jennings
well i don't agree with you actually on
this one
i think
design is subjective um i say i know
i like all the modern designs um
my favorite house is still on ground
designs was a castle with a big glass
extension around it
um
i'll probably have more glass on there
and i'd extend it from the outhouse to
the to the main house and have it all
glass
but again
that to me is sort of
where it comes down to where design is
subjective
um
and just because we don't like bits of
metal on it or render
um
i don't know i don't know i'm not
comfortable saying
imposing my design thoughts on other
people
are you are you giving a counter
proposal
or are you going to hold fire i'll hold
fire okay we see what the rest of the
panels are okay cancer curtis
i
[Music]
have
have you got a speaker on your on your
laptop if you can mute it and just make
sure everything's all muted because i
think you might be getting some feedback
from it either that will close the lid
while you speak um
on the materials with with the aluminium
in the glass i just
checking really whether the conservation
officer objected to those materials
being used but i wasn't sure they
had been
and actually yes i
reckon the previous comments that i
rather like this
i've got the conservation officer's
comments in front of me so i can read
what they said out thank you there's a
couple of points so i'll i think it's
important to do both um
they said that the impact of the
extensions would be exacerbated by the
design
the varying forms a material palette of
the single story extension has a
sophistication and complexity of design
at odds with the simple vernacular of
the list of building
they also said later on about the um the
glazed edition and it's quite lengthy so
i'm just going to try and summarize it
for you
whilst they they support the use
of a glazed extension um
they also said that care with use of a
steel frame for the glazed extension is
as vised as dependent on proportions and
finish of the frame it can appear
industrial instead timber frame with
glazed infill on a small base brick
plinth may offer an alternative option
as i say that's just in respect of the
materials there's obviously other
elements of their comments about the
scale and things like that thank you
chair
thank you very much anyone else got
anything i'd like to say council dixon
again i would only comment that uh if it
wasn't a listed building i wouldn't have
a problem with it but because it's
listing i think we need to protect it
understood
consensus therapy
yeah i think uh especially that frame in
there
should be timber to marry in more with
the listed building
okay understood anymore anymore
been proposed it was seconded wasn't it
um i'll chuck my two pennies worth in
for for what it's worth i've seen plenty
of listed buildings that have had metal
framed metal and glass framed extensions
put to them and they look great so i
wouldn't rule out something
purely because of the materials um for
me the big issue is the impact it's
having on that listed building and the
sheer scale of the um the the proposed
extension um and actually that was borne
out more so from the uh from the image
we saw of the property i think from the
agent's imagery uh for me it is a
huge change huge change to uh and
material a material negative change to
the listed building um
simply by the scale of the thing so i'm
going to be going with the officer
recommendation in the proposal um unless
anyone says anything i want to say at
this point we'll move to that proposal
which is to grant in line with officer
sorry it's not it's to refuse in line
with the officer's recommendation um
tonight's been very straightforward
isn't it uh could i have a show of hands
for those in favor of refusing in line
with remediation this is on the this is
on the ful
one two three six
against
three and abstentions
one
one um so
so it's four yeah that wasn't again so
six three um so committee resolves to
grant application twenty two zero zero
three eight two ful
oh my god
i am so sorry
oh
i'm gonna undo that
let's try that again
committee has resolved to refuse
application 2200 382 ful in line with
the officer recommendation we now need
to take the lbc the same proposal has
been made and we're seconded by uh
council mills as well could i please
have a share of hands for those in favor
of refusing the lbc
same against six and there's against the
refusal
is four so committee therefore resolves
to refuse application twenty two zero
zero three eight 383 lbc
forgive me for my faux pas there
okay i think that is that's done so
unless we have any urgent business
no no
uh and leaves me to say thank you very
much to all my members to all of the
members of the public that have spoken
tonight for their time and contributions
and we will see you next time thank you
very much
you